indira gandhi il y a 6 mois encore au
pouvoir aujourd'hui en prison elle est
accusée de corruption
les chambres de commerce annonce 250
mille offres d'emplois d'ici à décembre
ouverture aujourd'hui de la dernière
session parlementaire avant les
élections de mars 78 aragon fête ses 80
ans en compagnie des dirigeants du parti
communiste
bonsoir on le sentait depuis quelques
jours depuis la semaine dernière à l'onu
les contacts au très haut niveau entre
américains et soviétiques améliorer
nettement le climat entre les deux pays
après tout une période de tension marqué
par la croisade de jimmy carter sur les
droits de l'homme on l'a vu hier ce
dégel préparer en fait un coût
diplomatique
ressenti en israël comme le choc d'un
iceberg sur une plage
l'initiative américano soviétique tout
entière contenue dans une déclaration
officielle commune indiqué que dans le
cadre d'une négociation un processus de
paix a engagé au plus tard en décembre
77 les clés les questions clés était le
retrait des forces armées israéliennes
des territoires occupés en 67 et la
satisfaction des droits du peuple
palestinien ce qu'il ya sur tout nouveau
dans cette déclaration c'est qu'elle
soit commune publiée en même temps par
les américains et les soviétiques et
c'est qu'on y parlait aussi de
satisfaction des droits des palestiniens
et non plus de la simple sauvegarde de
leurs intérêts en israël on a réagi
vivement avec inquiétude à cette
déclaration vous entendrez dans quelques
instants
le président du conseil israélien
menahem begin enregistré il ya quelques
jours mais qui répète avec force qu'il
n'est pas question de discuter avec
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine comme le souhaiteraient les
américains et soviétiques
pas question non plus de reprendre de
rendre les territoires occupés
nécessaires à la sécurité d'israël
auparavant nous avons pensé vous
rappeler l'évolution du problème
palestinien au très rapidement depuis la
fondation de l'état d'israël comment on
en est passé de la notion de réfugié à
celle de peuple palestinien auquel on
reconnaît maintenant 1937 la population
palestinienne arabe était de 1 million
sans 3585 personnes puis il y eut la
première guerre israélo arabe de 1948
alors comment ça le grand exode des
palestiniens qui dans leur immense
majorité ne s'expatrient hier pas bien
loin le liban la syrie l'irak l'egypte 1
million de palestiniens prirent alors la
condition d'éternel réfugiés il recevait
à l'époque 37 dollars c'est à dire 190
francs actuels par an et par personne de
la part des organismes internationaux
en 1956 deuxième guerre israélo arabe
mais aussi françaises
1967 c'est l'intervention armée rapide
d'israël sur la cisjordanie le sinaï et
gaza cent soixante et onze mille
réfugiés palestiniens de plus qui cette
fois ont tendance à se regrouper au
liban où il crée des camps où
l'entraînement des fedayins est l'un des
plus durs et les plus efficaces qui
soient
allo
mais 1967 c'est aussi la fameuse
résolution 242 de l'onu résolution assez
vague mais dans laquelle on fait
toujours référence depuis dix ans et qui
octroie au peuple palestinien le statut
de réfugié
13,9 en 1974 après une longue marche
militaire idéologique et politique
yasser arafat est à la tribune des
nations unies et que dit il ce jour-là
il dit ceci je suis venu en tenant à la
fois un rameau d'olivier et larmes d'un
combattant de la liberté
ne laissez pas le rameau d'olivier
tomber de ma main
lentement et sûrement le fait
palestinien n'est plus seulement une
cause mais devient la représentativité
d'un peuple
1977 les états unis signent
conjointement avec l'union soviétique un
accord qui reconnaît au peuple
palestinien et droits réels
d'après un journal israélien la
déclaration américano soviétique sur le
proche orient aurait été communiqués dès
vendredi dernier au président du conseil
monsieur béguines par l'ambassadeur des
états unis en israël la discussion qui
suivit se seraient déroulés dans une
atmosphère évidemment très tendu et
aussitôt après monsieur begin et est
pris d'un malaise cardiaque comme ceux
qui l'avaient déjà alité pendant la
campagne électorale et après sa victoire
en juin dernier monsieur begin souffre
d'une péricardite il est actuellement à
l'hôpital ichilov de tel aviv et une
légère complication est apparu ce matin
dans son état de santé l'interview que
vous allez entendre a été réalisée
vendredi matin par philippe halphen deux
heures donc avant l'entretien avec
l'ambassadeur américain et le malaise
cardiaque de monsieur guy accepteriez
vous et gastriques avait alors empêché
elle m'a dit fais sa charge et
reconnaissait l'existence de l'état
d'israël
nous ne discuterons jamais avec le
soi-disant où elle peut tout à notre
avis est négociable sauf notre
destruction et le lp est destiné à
détruire israël
de lire leur soi-disant charte tir est
dit dans l'article 19 que l'état
d'israël n'a pas d'existence légale
je voudrais demander à chaque français
si un groupe de corse avait écrit un
texte où ils étaient ni que la
république française n'avait pas
d'existence légale si celle-ci
négocierait avec un tel groupe
je pourrais demander la même chose à
l'union soviétique et les ukrainiens
formé une organisation armée qui tuerait
des hommes des femmes et des enfants à
kiev est propre la mecque l'union
soviétique n'avait pas d'existence
légale est ce que cette dernière
négocierait
nous ne pouvons pas négocier avec une
organisation qui proclame que son but
final est de détruire israël parce
qu'israël est ici pour durer par
conséquent la seule idée que nous
puissions nous asseoir avec le
soi-disant olp est absolument
inconcevable chardja l'autre
aile à réaction monsieur le premier
ministre lorsque vous avez entendu le
président carter via s'ils souhaitaient
un foyer pour les palestiniens
c'est une déclaration qui a été faite
par le président carter et je suis en
rapport constant avec le président et le
gouvernement américains et nous traitons
ensemble de ce problème
des sports
pouvez-vous résister à une pression
américaine
cela dépend de la pression et cela
dépend des problèmes évoqués nous sommes
une nation souveraine et le soutiendront
nos droits légitimes
oui vraiment nous ferons
avait besoin des états unis
économiquement et pour des raisons
militaires
oui moi je connais bien les relations
qui existent entre nous et les états
unis elles sont très amicale et j'espère
qu'elle ne demeurerons
mais ne céderons jamais sur nos droits
car ils sont vitaux pour notre avenir et
à l'existence même de l'état d'israël
nous ne céderons jamais jeu car à quoi
servirait une assistance si le pays
n'existait plus
israël a besoin d'une assistance de
partout dans le monde parce que le pays
doit dépenser 30 2% de son produit
national brut pour le budget militaire
nous avons des problèmes qui n'existent
nulle part ailleurs et les gens de bonne
volonté est d'israël mais à condition
que ce soit israël état juif notre état
alors nous nous défendrons cet état
george josten bret what caused by
qu'elle serait à battre avis les
conditions nécessaires pour une paix
durable au proche orient
les conditions d'un traité de paix je
pense que les gens devraient comprendre
que d'abord il ya la guerre et
qu'ensuite il y à la paix etc la paix se
conclut par des traités mais qui sont
négociés
jusqu'à présent les pays arabes ont
refusé négocié avec nous un document
simple c'est en toutes les lois
internationales on appelle un traité de
paix
nous suggérons que l'on s'assoit autour
d'une table à genève ou ailleurs et
qu'on négocie un vrai traité de paix je
pense que c'est la seule façon normale
d'instaurer la presse c'est ainsi que
les choses se sont passées après la
première guerre mondiale après la
deuxième guerre mondiale et c'est arrive
également en extrême orient et cela
s'applique à toutes les nations et
israël ne doit pas être la seule nation
exclus de ce procédé ce qui est
appliquée à tous les autres nations du
monde doit être appliquée à l'état juif
aussi
pensez vous du fait main sur votre
sécurité vous ayez besoin des
territoires occupés je m'excuse je vous
demande monsieur le premier ministre si
pour la sécurité d'israël vous avez
besoin des territoires occupés
n'utiliserait pas une expression
semblables je sais ce que cela
signifierait si nous étions contraints
de reculer jusqu'à une ligne qui ne
serait séparé de la mère de douze
kilomètres chaque maison chaque homme
femme et enfant serait la portée des
mortiers l'artillerie nos ennemis et
cela je le refuse catégoriquement
il ya un accord national de tous les
partis politiques sont qu'une situation
comme celle ci ne se renouvellent jamais
des réunions
nous sommes ce sens il regardait par la
fenêtre vous verrez les salines de
bethléem et de ces collines il y a dix
ans notre parlement était bombardé par
des mortiers l'artillerie ennemie
chaque israélien dans son coeur
n'acceptera jamais qu'une situation
recommence en situation pareille cela ne
se renouvellera jamais et cela ne sera
pas parce que nous avons à coeur de
préserver la vie de chacun
monsieur le premier ministre dans le cas
d'une situation bloquée songe auriez
vous une solution militaire ge
excusez moi nous ne pensons qu'à la paix
et à la paix seulement et toute question
sur une soi disant solution militaire
nous est totalement étrangère
nous ne voulons pas d'une autre guerre
nous voulons la paix assez de viège
assez de sang versé nous ne prendrons
pas l'initiative de faire la guerre
mais bien sûr si nous sommes attaqués
nous nous défendrons et je crois que
notre armée est capable de le faire est
de défendre le pays et s'il est
nécessaire même de passer à la contre
attaque mais nous ne voulons pas d'un
développement pareil nous ne voulons
aucune guerre ni de guerre victorieuse
nous voulons la paix pour nous pour les
arabes pour leurs enfants et pour nos
enfants
voilà depuis cette déclaration de
vendredi la position israélienne n'a pas
changé d'un pouce on l'a bien vu
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne une
éventuelle participation aux légations
aux négociations de genève des
palestiniens du lp et israël se
considère aujourd'hui de plus en plus
isolé
indira gandhi en prison la fille de
nehru qui gouverna à l'inde pendant dix
ans qui fit l'admiration de beaucoup
pour son efficacité dans le
développement de l'inde mais dont la
poigne de fer sans le gant de velours
pezat sur l'opposition politique jusqu'à
mettre tous ses leaders à l'ombre indira
gandhi est à son tour en prison on s'y
attendait un peu depuis sa défaite
électorale au début de cette année les
nouveaux dirigeants de l'inde ont
inscrit contre elle un lourd dossier
pour corruption qui vient d'aboutir à
son arrestation et à celle de trois
anciens ministres on lui reproche
notamment d'avoir acheté une centaine de
jeeps tout terrain en utilisant sa
position officiels n'ont répondu madame
dans dix cantons n'est venu l'arrêter
les vrais motifs sont politiques jean
claude mignon
sur ces images là détenu d'aujourd'hui
c'est en mars cette année lé premier
ministre elle tient un meeting c'est la
campagne électorale des législatives
indira gandhi propose aux électeurs
d'assurer une nouvelle victoire au parti
du congrès qu'elle dirige la foule
scande son nom
22 mars cette année le parti du congrès
pour la première fois depuis
l'indépendance perd les élections indira
gandhi démissionne un an plus tôt la
haute cour de justice l'avait reconnu
coupable de manipulation électorale en
images son prestige été ternie elle
n'était donc pas une sainte d'autant que
lorsque l'opposition demandent sa
démission elle fokam l'état d'urgence et
elle en fait mettre les principales
personnalités en prison dont presque
tous les dirigeants de l'inde
d'aujourd'hui ils ne seront relâchés
qu'en janvier pour la campagne
électorale lorsqu'il me diras gandhi
parle de raisons politiques pour
expliquer son arrestation elle veut dire
c'est la réponse du berger à la bergère
officiellement l'arrestation est due à
la corruption de l'ancien premier
ministre indien elle avait déjà eu des
ennuis à cause du rôle important trop
important qu'elle avait confié son fils
qui fut lui aussi accusé de corruption à
indira gandhi on reproche d'avoir acquis
et jim comme celle sur laquelle vous la
voyez en train de défiler sur ces images
grâce à ses fonctions officielles la
police indienne ne précise pas pourquoi
en faire on doute qu'elle aisée ranger
dans son garage personnel quoi qu'il en
soit sa position reste forte en inde
ainsi que celles de son parti le congrès
et le gouvernement devra tenir compte de
sa popularité
l'action entreprise par les chambres de
commerce et d'industrie dans 152 villes
de france aujourd'hui est la première du
genre depuis leur création sous henri iv
on appelle cela les états généraux de
l'emploi ou plus officiellement la
journée nationale pour l'emploi cinq
ministres tous les délégués à l'emploi
du cnpf de nombreux préfets quarante
mille membres des chambres de commerce
étaient mobilisés pour une sorte de
chasse au trésor qui consistait en fait
a débusqués par tous le maximum
d'emplois on a même dit qu'il s'agissait
de se lancer à l'assaut des entreprises
le bilan affiché bien ses 150 mille
offres d'emploi pour les jeunes en
province françois go
cent cinquante mille offres d'emploi en
province voilà le bilan c'est en effet
ce qu'on recensait les chambres de
commerce depuis le mois de juin cent
cinquante mille offres d'emploi dans
soixante mille ont déjà trouvé preneur
et d'ici à la fin de l'année dans toute
la france cette fois ce sont deux cent
cinquante mille offres d'emplois qui
seront présentés par les entreprises
relevant des chambres de commerce alors
de quelle offre d'emploi s'agit-il eh
bien le concerne les entreprises de
commerce les emplois de services ainsi
que la petite et moyenne industrie sur
110 sont des contrats emploi formation
15 sont des contrats d'apprentissage 35
sur des stages de formation et 40 sont
des embauches durable et les 184 chambre
de commerce dans leur prospection n'ont
touché que 20 % des entreprises relevant
de leurs compétences parmi les villes
qui se place dans le peloton de tête
pour les offres on trouve marseille avec
plus de 5000 offres dont 2000 en bouche
durable orléans avec 2600 offres dont
mille embauches durable et besançon avec
2400 offres dont 1400 en bouche durable
parmi les régions l'aquitaine le nord
l'alsace bien sûr il faut rapprocher ces
offres des cent cinquante trois mille
emplois récemment annoncée par le cnpn
selon les chambres de commerce le
recouvrement et de 15% soit d'environ 23
mille emplois au total est dans
l'immédiat remet donc en présence de 280
mille offres d'emploi dans ces
conditions et si ces prévisions se
révèlent exactes les chiffres de
l'emploi pour les mois d'octobre et de
novembre devrait s'en trouver
sensiblement modifié
oui mais voilà à toulouse on faisait
plutôt grise mine aujourd'hui pour cette
journée nationale concorde c'est fini a
affirmé claude dufour le président de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
cette ville ce n'est pas parce que
concorde atterrira à new york at il dit
que la chaîne du supersonique
redémarrera concorde est parfait mais il
n'est pas rentable et il ne le sera
jamais le seul espoir de l'aéronautique
à toulouse c'est l'airbus à condition
que les allemands et les hollandais
achète cet appareil comme ils l'ont
promis et dans une interview à notre
confrère j'informe marcel cavaillé le
secrétaire d'état aux transports
confirme que l'hypothèse de l'arrêt de
fabrication a été prise en compte par
l'aérospatiale dans sa position
concernant l'emploi le plan de charge
repose maintenant
sur les avions airbus et transall est
aussi un avion nouveau moyen courrier
marcel cavaillé chiffre les pertes sur
concorde 120 millions de francs pour
chacun des seize appareils en enfin
fabrique a pas davantage le coût du
programme actuel est de 10 milliards
pour l'état trois fois plus que prévu
actuellement cinq concorde reste a vendu
les constructeurs sont ont dû ont du
coup son du couperet pardon sont du coup
prêt à offrir des propositions de
location à court ou à moyen terme et la
compagnie singapore airlines seraient
intéressés
ça s'est passé assez discrètement mais
aujourd'hui c'était la rentrée
parlementaire pour 475 députés et 295
sénateurs si vous connaissez la
constitution ces chiffres peuvent vous
surprendre c'est simplement qu'une
douzaine de députés sont devenus
sénateurs la semaine dernière et
laissent leurs sièges vacants
l'assemblée nationale jusqu'en mars 78
et il y à aussi 12 sénateurs de plus de
nouveaux sièges ayant été créées les
préoccupations des parlementaires vont
être dans l'immédiat l'examen et le vote
du budget mais surtout les perspectives
électorales du printemps prochain alain
chaillot
au menu de cette toute dernière session
quelques order comme dès la semaine
prochaine un projet de loi sur
l'informatique et la liberté un autre
sur la protection des consommateurs dans
les opérations de crédit et plus tard
encore un projet sur l'indemnisation des
rapatriés mais le plat de résistance
sera sans aucun doute l'examen du budget
78 un budget de 400 milliards que
députés et sénateurs vont examiner avec
le plus grand soin un véritable dépeçage
avec son inévitable cortège de
discussion d'intervention de
condamnation mais au bout du compte à
coup sûr un vote favorable à la veille
de cette discussion budgétaire le 11
octobre le premier ministre prononcera
un discours que l'on qualifie déjà
d'importants à cette occasion raymond
barre présentera le bilan et tracera les
perspectives de l'action gouvernementale
intervention très attendue dans la
majorité car elle pourrait être une
sorte de pré face au programme électoral
que giscardien et centristes attentes du
chef de gouvernement pour les élections
de mars 78 car c'est évident la
proximité de l'échéance électorale sera
présente à tous les esprits et
mobilisera plus encore que les débats
l'attention et l'énergie des députés et
des sénateurs
en conséquence il faudra suivre avec
attention le comportement de chacun des
partis l'on peut ce soir se poser
légitimement quelques questions voici
les deux principales la première comment
le rpr et jacques chirac manoeuvreront
il pour préserver et développer leur
originalité au sein de la majorité
deuxième question comment va se
répercuter la querelle de la gauche dans
les relations entre parlementaires
socialistes et communistes à cet égard
cette session sera à n'en pas douter
intéressante à suivre
ce qui est aussi l'avis d'alain poher
réélu tout à l'heure et pour la
quatrième fois président du sénat
ont fait l'essentiel de cette session
c'est budget toujours et dès maintenant
les commissions vent et vacances les
rapporteurs qui n'était pas renouvelable
se sont mis à étudier les différents
textes du budget alors si on sème les
textes qui vont venir
en discussion en séance publique
il ya ceux qui n'avaient pas été votés à
la fin de la dernière session est ce que
le gouvernement va nous donner à pour
l'instant devant rencontrer dès à
présent à public demain et devant
recevoir le nouveau secrétaire d'état
chargé des relations avec le parlement
c'est un peu prématuré que je vous dise
la priorité les discussions mais je peux
estimer qu'à partir si vous voulez du 15
octobre au sénat est en mesure de
commencer les discussions des textes en
science publique
au parti communiste aujourd'hui une
parenthèse dans la turbulence politique
habituel et cela pour honorer l'un des
plus grands poètes et écrivains vivants
de notre temps louis aragon on fêtait
ses 80 ans il était l'invité du bureau
politique avec dominique laurie le
cheminement des relations du poète avec
son parti relation toute empreinte de
fidélité mais une fidélité qui
s'interrogent et qui s'inquiète louis
aragon 81 cent cinquante années de
fidélité au parti une fidélité peut être
un peu plus discret avec l'âge le tribun
du front populaire l'auteur des
communistes a fait place un homme qui
semble au soir de sa vie dominée par une
interrogation plutôt que par des
certitudes quelques nuages des réserves
parfois des critiques à l'égard de
l'urss lors de l'invasion de la
tchécoslovaquie puis avec la disparition
de son journal les lettres françaises et
la mort d'elle à triolet aragon se
réfugie dans le silence un silence qui
ne l'empêchent pas d'assister au 22e
congrès et aux grandes manifestations
politiques du pc le silence peut être
une certaine manière de rester fidèle à
son parti c'est cette histoire comme lui
du poète et de son parti qu'évoque gens
je marche notre parti
ce qu'il est devenu
doit beaucoup
à une activité dans tous ses aspects
tant apport politique
est en oeuvre littéraire
l'un et l'autre ensemble
figure au premier rang
de tout ce qui a fait au long des années
le parti du socialisme aux couleurs de
la france
deux rapts d'enfants dans la même
journée en italie le petit fils du
président de la ce et turin club de
football a été enlevé dans un jardin
public par deux hommes qui ont assommé
sa grand-mère et son garde du corps
l'enfant à 4 ans il a une jambe plâtrée
c'est la troisième fois qu'on s'en prend
à l'entourage de monsieur barbero qui
est aussi un industriel du bâtiment et
c'est la triste suite dé de l'industrie
des enlèvements en italie et puis en
suisse et là c'est la première fois on a
enlevé une petite fille aux noms
célèbres patino c'est la petite nièce du
roi de l'état éric gilbert l'exécution
du rapt des gangsters bien renseignés
sur l'annuaire des milliardaires guette
la petite graziella ortiz patino sur le
chemin de son école un établissement
public de la capitale faubourg ultra
résidentiel de genève où réside sa
famille lorsque l'enfant paraît dans une
voiture conduite par le majordome des
patino les gangsters à l'aide d'une alfa
romeo bloc le véhicule assomme le
chauffeur et s'empare de la petite fille
en la clau formant semble-t-il plus tard
dans la matinée ses ravisseurs deux
hommes de 25 30 ans parlant français
prennent contact avec les parents nés
sans avancer de chiffres de rançon
l'afer a été préparé depuis longtemps
une preuve s'il alfa romeo qui leur a
servi au rapt a été volé dans les
environs de genève il ya quelques jours
en revanche les plaques
d'immatriculation qu'ils ont apposé sur
le véhicule ont été dérobés à gênes il y
a déjà deux mois pour nous ce serait une
affaire classique mais ici en suisse
c'est une première le seul précédent que
l'on connaît son effet est un enlèvement
survenu en 1952 il était l'oeuvre d'un
jeune déséquilibré c'est donc bien la
première fois que les suisses sont
confrontés à l'industrie du kidnapping
certes sur leur territoire il ya déjà eu
des tractations dans des affaires comme
la sphère révelli beaumont mais jamais
c'était des personnes vivantes ici qu
étaient concernés aussi ce soir au delà
de l'inquiétude très vive et bien
légitime qu inspire à genève le sort de
cet enfant les suisses sont très choqués
ils ont l'impression que leur ville
jusque là épargné est maintenant prise
dans l'engrenage infernal du banditisme
international c'est un petit peu comme
si un pan de leur légendaire neutralité
venait brutalement de s'effondrer
avec vous jean claude narcy les autres
de mètres de ce journal est d'abord
alors les pilotes de se détourna meurent
de ce détournement d'avion de la japan
airlines réduisent otages les deux
otages du décès huit ont été libérés sur
l'aéroport d'alger cet après midi il
était 16 heures 15 exactement les cinq
membres du commando et six prisonniers
libérés par gouvernement japonais ont
été amenés sous bonne garde pour une
destination inconnue c'est tout ce que
l'on sait soir car les journalistes
étrangers ont été tenus à l'écart des
opérations voilà donc comme vous le
disiez les pilotes de cette triste
aventure qui a débuté mercredi dernier
le paris tokyo avec à son bord 137
passagers et 14 membres de l'équipage
avaient été détournés par 5 terroriste
obligeant le commandant de bord à
atterrir à dacca au bangladesh le
commando a exigé 300 millions de
centimes et la libération de prisonniers
politiques détenus au japon les pilates
relâcher les otages par petits paquets
et le gouvernement japonais céder sur
les exigences puis dimanche et
tractations étaient interrompues des
militaires du bangladesh profité de la
confusion pour une tentative de coup
d'état qui avortaient dans la tour de
contrôle de dakar des officiers qui
participait aux discussions avec le
commando était même tué par les rebelles
enfin l'avion quitté dakar hier après
midi se posait au koweit sept otages
étaient alors libéré en échange de
carburant une nouvelle escale en syrie
dix otages étaient encore libéré et puis
cet après midi c'était la fin du
cauchemar pour les derniers otages alger
acceptant pour des raisons humanitaires
d'offrir l'asile au dc 8 le japon dit on
ne demandera pas l'extradition des
terroristes
violents incidents à rome aujourd'hui
après les funérailles d'un militant
d'extrême-gauche des manifestants ont
attaqué les sièges du mouvement social
italien les néofascistes la police est
intervenue
des coups de feu ont été tirés on ignore
encore le bilan des affrontements
nicole pasquier déléguée à la condition
féminine et les 26 délégué régional ont
déjeuné à midi avec le président de la
république même giscard d'estaing le
chef de l'état leur a rappelé
l'importance fondamentale qui
l'attachent l'action menée en faveur de
la femme et nicole pasquier à sa sortie
de l'elysée a rappelé la priorité de
cette action à jacky mme coakley
c'est la priorité c'est je crois quand
même que la femme puisse accéder au
monde de l'emploi la formation
professionnelle et bien c'est une étape
qu'elle doit franchir il faut qu'une
femme sont toujours capables de
travailler parce qu'elle pouvait être
seul parce que même quand elle quand
elle est mariée est là il y as intéresse
qu elles puissent débrouillait ce qu'il
puisse être autonome et sans moi même un
meilleur tour donc c'est une première
étape parce que vous puissiez pas encore
évident il ya beaucoup à faire dans ce
domaine les jeunes filles sont très
marquées par l
nouveau vol de réémetteurs de télévision
les habitants d'autun en saône et loire
sont privés pour la deuxième fois en six
mois de la première chaîne de télévision
le réémetteur a été volée la nuit
dernière comme au mois de mars dernier
depuis 1971 les vols et les attentats
contre les émetteurs de télévision roc'h
trédudon rennes marseille bastia cahors
et narbonne et bien ces vols et ces
attentats ont coûté 50,5 millions de
francs de dommages qui représente
l'installation de 16 stations de
télévision couleur une bonne nouvelle
toutefois l'émetteur de bastia à
plastiqué en août dernier a été remis en
service et les habitants du nord-ouest
de la corse peuvent voir notre journal
ce soir
niki lauda après sa performance au grand
prix des états unis remporté par james
bond où il s'est classé 4e à d'ores et
déjà repris son titre de champion du
monde des conducteurs puisqu'il ne reste
plus que deux épreuves à disputer le
grand prix du canada
le grand prix du japon
mathématiquement le dha ne peut plus
être rattrapé par ses concurrents
enfin guy drut est amère après le refus
de la fédération française d'athlétisme
de le revoir évoluer dans les milieu de
l'athlétisme il l'a dit dans le journal
d'yves mourousi à 13 heures en fait
notre champion du 110 m haies n'aspirait
qu'à faire bénéficier les jeunes de son
expérience en animant des stages et bien
les dirigeants de la fédération
française d'athlétisme ont sans aucun
doute manqué l'occasion aujourd'hui de
s'honorerait en montrant un peu de
mansuétude
on trouve toutes les températures
aujourd'hui 12 à dijon et à besançon
mais 22 tout de même à nice ajaccio et
perpignan demain sur le sud des alpes et
le midi méditerranéen le temps sera
ensoleillé mais il se couvrira ensuite
sur le reste du pays le temps sera doux
mais très nuageux et passagèrement
pluvieux les pluies deviendront plus
forte l'après-midi sur la moitié nord
ouest des éclaircies apparaîtront le
soir de la bretagne la vendée à la
frontière belge où les vents deviendront
fort il y soufflera même en rafales sur
les côtes alors attention et puis
températures en hausse généralement
j'ai participé avec jean-louis burgat et
dans la même équipe qu'à la longue alain
bombard et haroun tazieff à une épreuve
automobile qui s'annonçait passionnante
pour nous puisqu'elle consistait à
parcourir un certain nombre de
kilomètres sur les routes de monsieur
tout le monde en consommant le moins de
carburant possible ça c'est intéressant
ça s'est passé dans la magnifique région
de pau à biarritz trois épreuves une en
ville une sur la route une sur
l'autoroute c'est vrai qu'au point de
vue consommation les résultats sont
spectaculaires nous avons fait moins de
5 litres aux 100 km avec une diesel mais
si certaines parties du parcours se
faisait dans des conditions correctes
avec une conduite normale il faut
reconnaître que pour faire des économies
de carburant nous avons presque jouer
les casse cou en montagne à cause de la
moyenne et qu'en ville c'est la voiture
qui a beaucoup souffert jean-louis
burgat vous donne à son tour ses
impressions sur cette épreuve le mobile
économisera
pour remporter le mobile économie rhône
il faut une voiture qui consomme peu
c'est simple apparemment mais ce n'est
pas aussi vrai que cela un exemple dans
la brochure éditée par l' agence pour
les économies d'énergie la renault 5 gt
elle consomme 8 litres cette hausse en
ville et la fiat 127 10 litres 4 or dans
le mobile la fiat a battu la renault
pourquoi une telle différence entre les
essais officiels est le mobile en dehors
d'une certaine mansuétude dont les
experts ont pu faire preuve pour les
mesures de consommation de la r5 gt est
là sa présentation il n'en demeure pas
moins que cette différence est le
résultat d'une forme de pilotage propre
à cette course démarrée en seconde faire
cogner le moteur à 5 km heure dans
l'épreuve urbaine dévaler des pentes en
4e sont jamais rétrogradé en oubliant la
[ __ ] de frein se faire aspirer par
d'autres voitures c'est ainsi qu'il faut
piloter pour remporter le mobile
économie rhône tous les vainqueurs ont
utilisé ce mode de conduite qui n'a rien
à voir avec le pilotage de monsieur tout
le monde cela dit comment faire pour
rendre à l'épreuve sa vérité c'est la
cadrature du cercle répondent les
organisateurs constatent avec raison que
certains concurrents parfaitement
néophytes comme alain bombard ont tout
de même réussi 4 litres 44 au sens avec
une golf diesel et puis c'est la seule
course au monde qui met en piste des
voitures strictement de série d permet
de constater que l'on peut encore
acheter une renault 5 gt elle ou une
fiat 127 qui n'ont consommé qu'un peu
plus de 6 litres aux cent sur 300
kilomètres de routes encombrées c'est
certainement plus sérieux que les
résultats de certains rallyes ou
épreuves de vitesse qui met côte à côte
des voitures n'ayant plus rien à voir
sinon dans les lignes avec un modèle
vendu au client
alors les organisateurs feront mieux la
prochaine fois bonne soirée à tous au
nom de toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité
dernier journal jean pierre pernaut vers
23h30 merci